[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host we help people
build well do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships my
co-host today dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author we'll be answering your questions
about your life and your money thank you
for jumping in america the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two
five jeff is going to start us off this
hour in cincinnati hi jeff how are you
hey jet
i'm i'm doing good dave how are you
better than i deserve what's up
well i'm kind of a new follower i just
found you earlier this year
had some questions about potentially
refinancing our house
we originally bought it back in january
of 2021
this was obviously before we knew you
and we we got a 30-year loan
at two and a half percent
and now
kind of considering do we move to a 15
year but my biggest concern with that is
that we're giving up that two and a half
percent rate to
go somewhere around five percent or so
you're right
i would not i would not do that you're
right
okay no you can you keep this
keep the existing mortgage you have
if you calculate a 30-year mortgage
and you calculate a 15-year mortgage at
the same interest rate in your case two
and a half
and you pay the difference
like you like you took out a 30 and you
pay the extra amount as and the
difference between a 15 payment and a 30
payment it will pay off in exactly 15
years
okay you do not have to refinance to pay
a loan off in 15 years you just have to
pay it like it's a 15-year payment and
it'll pay right out
or more of course and then it would pay
out even sooner so never refinance just
to move from a 30 to a 15
because you take on the closing costs at
a minimum and in this case you'd go up
an interest rate so you never do that
just pay extra on it and you'll get
there
okay um that was easy wasn't it as far
as
as far as how much uh like house i can
afford uh we were well within the
um 25
kind of calculating it off of two and a
half percent rate that we have great um
but
with rates now i know we're not
refinancing um but that would obviously
put us
probably closer to the 30 mark do we
have well it doesn't matter you could it
doesn't matter you're fine you know the
reality is your house payment is a
fourth of your take-home pay at a
15-year
on two and a half and so you're fine
the reason we put that in place is not
to keep people from buying homes and
john people are really mad right now
about because you hate home house prices
apparently i hate home ownership and i'm
an unrealistic old
boomer or whatever other terms of
derision you can throw at my bald head
but the um
i don't care if you get a house you
can't afford it doesn't affect me it
affects you if you buy a house you can't
afford jeff's in good shape he's not got
any issues but
here's the thing and i've been answering
this question the same way for 30 years
like we have people call us from
california well dave you're you know you
can't buy a house in california for that
uh that means you can't buy you can't
buy a house that's california for that
that's what that means
you also may not be able to buy bentley
uh you also may not be you know when i
grew up this county that we live in is
the 11th wealthiest county in the nation
the wealthiest county in tennessee
williamson county tennessee where you
and i are sitting right now where both
of us live now when i was growing up
that's where the rich people lived
and we said stuff like you can't afford
to live there
and you know what not everybody can
afford to live there you know everybody
can afford to live on rodeo drive or in
downtown manhattan or downtown tokyo or
downtown london it's freaking expensive
and so sometimes you just have to say i
can't afford it number one but number
two here the reason for this is we know
from the data of doing the 30 years that
your most likely
way to become wealthy is to get your
home paid off as soon as possible and
all other debts too
because it frees up your most powerful
wealth building tool and so if you keep
a mortgage around like it's a pet
for your whole life because you're
thinking well i'm always going to have a
mortgage and the only way i can afford a
mortgage the only way i'm ever going to
get a house because i'll never get a
house i never get a house i'm so stuck
and it's just not fair and life's not
fair and i'm a four-year-old on the
cereal aisle throwing a fit and i want
captain crunch dad blame it you know and
it's just like a and you just
everybody's acting like that right now
and so i'm sorry you i'm
i'm sorry that when i was a kid i
couldn't live in williamson county i
couldn't afford it my family didn't make
that kind of money i'm sorry i had a
traumatized childhood i'm sorry
but it's the way life is and so you know
the answer is no the reason you tell
yourself no is so you can tell yourself
yes later so if you go buy a house you
can't afford
and you go take car payments out that
you can't afford and you go take which
nobody can you go take out a student
loan and you go take out mastercard and
visa and american distress you're going
to be normal and normal is you work your
whole life
and give all of the money you earn to
someone else in the form of payments and
retire broke and hope social insecurity
will take care of you who the crap wants
to be normal right
and so you've got to break this cycle
and not be angry
at me or at the world or instagram or
twitter or whatever it is you're angry
at this week
because house prices went up
i'm
really sorry i i don't want you to be
upset and i don't want you to not have a
house but also don't want you to do
something stupid that's going to keep
you broke your whole life i i'll throw a
third one on there dave
i have found in my life when i've had a
30-year mortgage and i've had a couple
of those in the 15-year
i can have all the best intentions with
a 30-year mortgage
but when it comes down to it
every single month somebody invites me
out to a thing or hey we're all going
out to this thing
and
whether i've got the best intentions or
i've got all the willpower in the world
it's really hard for me to make that to
double that payment or to make that gap
payment between
the 30-year note is requiring me to pay
and what i could be paying for that
15-year
with the 15-year i'm locked into it i
got to do it
one of the things i figured out when i
very first started doing this stuff with
financial peace when i started studying
rich people is
they put
smart things on autopilot
yes i don't want to think about it a
hundred percent of the 15-year mortgages
pay off in 15 years or less yeah a
hundred percent or they get foreclosed
on i mean 100 of them do okay people
that take out a 30 promising to pay a 15
the studies say 92 percent do not
stick with the schedule i would say if
you if you put a system in place that
you have to be in the top eight percent
is the only way you win you lose you're
gonna that's dumb i just was listening
to some obesity researchers today and
they were talking about step one create
an environment where you can at least
attempt to be successful get the junk
out of your house yeah right you can't
have it all there and say i'm gonna make
good choices because you're not going to
make a choice james claire talks about
that in atomic habits yeah he talks
about the exact same thing what is it
you're trying to create a habit then
don't put stuff that's contrary to the
habit right in front of you the opposite
of paying the mortgage off early and
another autopilot is the 401ks that's
why they're so successful you never see
the money it just comes out of your
check automatically are an auto draft on
your checking account for your roth iras
or your kids 529 you auto you're an
automatic investor
and david bachman had a best-selling
book automatic millionaire or whatever
it was called uh and he said just put
everything on automatic and you know
what there's something to that and so
quit do quit thinking you're like have
super powers just to get to buy crap you
can't afford it's a bad idea
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
one of the things we are doing today and
this week is we're talking about the
importance of insurance
uh the subject no one likes to talk
about
everybody say it with me insurance sucks
until you need it
right and then it doesn't and then when
you got it and you need it it's like the
right kind and you did the right thing
but it's confusing too many people buy
the wrong stuff they spend the wrong
money on the wrong things but insurance
is a huge blessing because people that
build wealth not only play offense they
also play defense and insurance is the
defense side and so in honor of uh this
insurance week here we're talking about
the confidence in your coverage
program that george camel put out uh
with our ramsey trusted people and all
this details on your insurance it's
really good stuff donna is on the line
donna's in pensacola florida so donna
talk about insurance and the importance
of it in your life
donna
donna
i'm here can you hear me yes ma'am hey
how are you
i'm good how are you today good talk
about insurance and the importance of it
in your situation
so i wanted to speak specifically to
insurance and life insurance with second
marriages
there's a lot of people out there with
second marriages and it adds in some
factors that
maybe you hadn't thought about before
so what happened in my situation was
my husband passed away two years ago and
when i contacted
the
department at his work for life
insurance it turns out they never got
his change of beneficiary form
so when we both got married we both
filled out the change of beneficiary
forms
and we sent them in
and
apparently they got mine and didn't get
his
so all of his life insurance went to
his ex-wife who you know
hated him and didn't want to have
anything to do with him
and so we had no idea we were married
for three years we had no idea that they
never received that document and we
could have known we could have known
because they send you back a copy that
they received it we never followed up to
check on it
another thing that happened was
you get when you retire or die you get
paid for your unused vacation time and
unused sickly
one of they're considered separate leave
and one of them has a beneficiary for
him and the other one does it
well he'd worked there for 30 years so
you know back when he was 18 he had
signed a beneficiary form for whichever
one has one
and totally forgot that that even
existed
because it's not like a huge amount of
money like life insurances so turns out
he didn't change that beneficiary for
him so it went to somebody else
and then i got the other one
like his parents or something or
no he he was married for a short time
back when he was 18 so it probably went
back to that wife oh my gosh okay um
yeah and then the sucks all the
ex-wife's got the money
all the time well i got the tsp
but uh
the life insurance i think was higher at
that point in time
um
and another thing that i came across and
i don't know which this is from i don't
know if it's from his military time or
from a life insurance policy or what it
was from
but there was somebody who before they
would distribute funds i had to come up
with the marriage dates and divorce
dates of the previous
spouses
so he'd been married a short time when
he was very young when he was in the
military and then he'd been married for
a long time for his second marriage and
i was the third so
i looked through all his forms and i
found all that and had it but i i called
up you know people that i knew that were
on a second marriage i'm like
i guess because they were trying to they
were trying to prove that he wasn't
married to more than one person
yes they wanted to make sure that he
really was divorced from previous
marriages wow
yeah so those are all things that i'm
recommending that people look into don't
just assume you've got
all your details in order
um i mean so when you went through the
confidence in your coverage series is
that the kind of thing that jumped out
to you or did you pick up something else
uh the thing that jumped out to me in
that
because i had been uh i have been
listening intently and for a few years
and so i had
you know background on almost everything
but one thing that jumped out to me in
the little questionnaire that you take
yourself was about long-term care
insurance and i'm 57 so i'm not 60 yet
but it caused me to check into it
because i have a diagnosis that i
thought might make me ineligible and it
did
so it just
it's a kidney disease it doesn't affect
my life i'm totally healthy i just have
to get my blood checked every year to
make sure it isn't progressing so i
don't think about it a lot but it's
enough to make me ineligible for
long-term care insurance i wouldn't be
able to get life insurance now things
like that that if you get a diagnosis
and i've had the diagnosis for 20 years
so if you get it when you're younger and
you find out you're ineligible later for
these things you need to go ahead and
build up your nest egg and and be
prepared for those kinds of expenses for
real for real so it sounds like what
you're you're mentioning here is it goes
back to one word that i just keep
hearing over and over as you're talking
and that's this idea of
being highly intentional
about the hard conversations there is a
chance no matter how small
um
that
something may happen to one of you and
we need to make sure all of our ducks in
a row and we need to make that extra
phone call at work sit down with our
insurance agent and make sure we're
covered
make sure these things are in order so
that if the unthinkable happens which in
your case it did
we're covered everybody's on the same
page
he was 49 when he drowned in the gulf of
mexico so if you think oh i'll check
into it i'm older don't check into it
when you're older when it comes to
second marriages there's so many other
things that
another thing to think about is
the relationship your spouse has with
your own kid
because you need to think when you get
married a second time you need to think
okay
yes we our life insurance policies are
mirrored they say
the same thing everything will go to our
kids but that's only if you die at the
same time if one of you dies first and
the person who survives doesn't have a
relationship with your kid and
everything is going to your spouse that
you love and you chose
and then and then later on
they die
everything goes to their kids and your
kids get nothing
you might want some stuff to go to your
kids when you die because your spouse
may live longer and your spouse may
marry somebody else
and then there is some part you don't
even know gets everything and then your
your kids and your spouse's kids don't
get any of it
so it gets through it gets super
complicated to do a will and to do the
beneficiaries and everything yeah
right and thinking through not
necessarily the first movement the first
rhythm
if something happens but the second one
is the one that's hard to anticipate
yeah yeah because all the beneficiary
forms i've seen say if you fill this out
then boom that person gets it whatever
you want happens if you don't fill it
out
then
the system has to go through the process
of figuring out who really gets it and
if it's your first marriage it's going
to be the spouse if your second marriage
holy cow you have no idea what's going
to happen yeah yeah wow that's good
insight donna thank you for sharing all
that wow pretty important
crazy crazy stuff
well you can uh go to
ramseysolutions.com
and check out the confidence in your
coverage series there is a five part
series there they're all very short
they're all very fun and funny because
it is george campbell after all
and um ramsey solutions dot com slash
confidence it is a free
five-day video guide to walk you through
the different kinds of insurance
and donna's insights are
really
really valuable there
um and
you know the thing is john these aren't
things right doing a will
making sure your beneficiaries are right
making sure the name on your mutual fund
account has changed uh all those kinds
of things are um
none of this is like
sit down have fun
no this is not like i get to do the most
fun thing this weekend i'm working on
this crap right but um but it it you
know when you've got all that in order
that is one way you are saying to your
wife your husband your kids i love you i
love you yeah even when i'm not here i
love you yeah it's it's that level of
diligence and by the way it is the
difference in poor people and rich
people often
wealthy people do this kind of stuff
uh people who well having money doesn't
matter well it's
kind of a correlation there you know do
the do the intentional diligent thing
take care of the little things and the
big things tend to take care of
themselves
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
oh
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney number one best-selling
author and ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions a whole bunch of folks
visiting us today thank you for visiting
us guys by the way if you're ever in the
franklin tennessee south of nashville
area and want to stop by it is a free
visit to the ramsey
uh complex including the visitors center
here in the lobby and you can watch the
show we tape the show every day from one
to four or we do the show live
it is also simultaneously taped from one
to four
central every day and in the middle of
that lobby is the debt free stage on
that stage is jonathan and amy hey guys
how are you good how are you good
welcome where do you guys live
um watkins glen new york all right cool
welcome to nashville how much data have
you paid off a hundred and two thousand
all right
how long did this take four years good
for you and your range of income during
that time uh 60 to 75 000. cool what do
y'all do for a living i'm a teaching
assistant
i was a
vehicle purchaser for a scrap yard and i
currently am a teaching assistant now oh
okay both of you good good for you cool
so what kind of debt was the 102 000
a lot of things it was credit card debt
personal loans family loans uh we owed
some library money like
we owned fire we owned everything the
library yeah it's like one of those
dreams you have in the middle of the
night that you forgot from 30 years ago
you're in a hawk to the library that's
knowing you're not you're not doing well
it's pretty bad it's actually really bad
when you don't have money to buy a
coffee and then you're like let's just
transfer money over and yeah it's cool
like it's all good so you're normal
pretty normal normal's no fun and you
decided to change four years ago what
caused you to do this ramsey stuff tell
us the story
well so our church was doing a um
ramsay yeah
appreciation thank you i'm sorry i'm
really nervous no trouble
but um
so i mean really they were the catalyst
higher hope um in big flats new york was
like the huge catalyst to it i thought
we were fine honest to god i just
thought credit cards were just normal
and we pay them when we can
when we want to exactly
um
so my husband was super nerdy and really
wanted to get into this and i was very
reluctant and i said let's just try it
like let's look at everything kind of
try it was a little ramsey-ish through
the course i was kicking and screaming
oh okay um but then i really got on
board especially when we started seeing
the little ones it was so big for us
um he was a great big support i mean he
kind of just
i don't know the whole time you were
just not harsh but like
kind of real but
it was really good like i don't know we
just and we saw our girls kind of
prospering
i had never seen money talk
um he hadn't either but the girls i mean
they play your show every saturday on
alexa they say alexa play the ramsay
show and we listen to it so it's i mean
that's our why that's a huge why very
cool it's awesome so and they love
knowing that they can plan for the
future
i mean and they're seven and ten so i
love it it's awesome it's very good so
you kicked and screamed all the way
through the course or up until the last
one or all the way through and really he
won you over simply by causing the money
to start winning
okay so i would say it was about two
weeks and we started making friends and
we went through a live course so it was
really nice to see other people kind of
going through the same struggles um
and the same
kind of
i don't know tantrum moments that i had
take some of the shame away from the
process it does yeah
um y'all going through the same thing
yeah and then we actually like i don't
know about you about three in
um i kind of all clicked and we were
starting to pay off more and it was
doing really good and we had our
emergency fund and it was really
yeah and then we taught it at our church
oh whoa you went all the way we did it
was full circle
but i kind of hoped i like let the shame
like my hair straighten or broke one
time and i was like guys i'm not buying
it's not my budget so this is what you
have to look at this week i'm really
sorry
this is important and you survived i did
more importantly did the rods and cones
in there did they survive too yeah
everything was great
everything was great wow yeah it felt
like weird to be weird but it feels even
better now to be weird so so jonathan
what was it like dragging
like a hurricane through this process
it wasn't that bad
we were we were together but she just
had struggles tonight
well done you guys all right so what do
you tell people now that your
coordinators now that you paid off 102
000 you're actual professionals now what
do you tell them the key to getting out
of debt is
doing the budget you just got to start
somewhere and
budget it's huge it's huge it is your
guideline it's your everything i mean
it's neither one or the other telling
each other you can't do it it's
literally there on paper
so i mean amy's talking like a real free
spirit but a real free spirit who had a
vote
you had you had control in this you
weren't
john the one telling you what to do both
of you are voting and you're agreeing
and like two grown-ups this is where
we're going and this is the price we're
gonna pay if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else absolutely and you said something
powerful you shift the blame to this
piece of paper and so i don't hate
jonathan for saying no
yeah we can we're in our teeth at this
budget right but yeah the budget said
the budget said yes this is the budget
what was your what was your favorite uh
altercation
what was the biggest fight the biggest
fight you had
okay so he remembers his but you go
ahead and answer
okay
so you have your fun money and i decided
to grow my fun money by selling like
thrifted items and stuff and my husband
said well you can't do that
you're gone money
it can't grow because you've got to pay
up your debt and our debt together and
she wanted to take her money and like
invest it and then keep her extra money
oh i know yeah yeah
i got the program here
yeah it was a kicking and screaming
moment in the very beginning you have to
give some grace i love it
so yeah that was that was big jonathan
yeah you guys you're perfect for each
other i mean y'all
like you make his life fun
i mean
and he makes sure there's water coming
out of the faucet every month
yeah it's true
you guys got us down
you guys are all right this is great
this is a perfect y'all are a perfect
couple this is great so well done i'm so
proud of y'all thank you how's it feel
to be free it feels amazing awesome our
marriage is
way better than anything i could have
imagined that's why i could take the
different job too as a job switch
because i've been the same job for 12
years and then we got that free like we
can make some choices he's going back to
school um to be a teacher so oh good you
know he's living out his dream too and
that's really cool that's very cool
that's incredible and that wasn't going
to happen as long as you just kept
swimming in credit card debt no way no
there's no way
you guys are powerful well done thank
you for going to be a teacher man yeah
amen thank you man we need good people
teaching he's pretty good at being a ta
so he'll be a really good teacher amen
good stuff all right you brought the
kiddos with you what are their names and
ages
um eliza is 10.
and marlena is seven all right very good
we've got a copy of the
baby steps millionaires book for you
because that's the next chapter in your
story for sure i mean uh from kicking
and screaming to coordinating we going
all the way through the whole thing i
like it that's that's the best kind
right there and we've also got a copy of
total money makeover for you to give to
somebody in one of your classes and
we'll give you a one-year subscription
to financial peace university you can
find somebody that needs to go through
the class when you're leading it and
help them out doing that thank you of
course that comes with the every dollar
premium and this is the brand new
lessons that just came out brand new
videos just came out so make sure you're
jumping in there and getting all that
done when you're coordinating good stuff
thank you guys so much you're incredible
i'm so proud of you you're rock stars
thank you heroes took care of your life
man jonathan amy eliza and marlena
watkins glenn new york 102 000 paid off
in four years making 60 to 75 000 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
powerful
powerful
good stuff
good stuff
grown-ups being grownups it's a good
thing in america raising grownups yeah
raising another patch of grown-ups
that's really good this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today sierra is with us in
portland oregon hi sierra welcome to the
ramsey show
hello thanks for having me sure what's
up um we just completed baby steps two
through four and we have approached baby
steps five but my husband and i have a
disagreement um
when it comes to saving for your kids
college fund
i'm all for it and my husband is against
it
against
saving for your kids
yes
he does not think he should pay for his
kids college or anything having to do
with it
correct how come
uh so we both went
to college got our bachelor's degree
my husband about four years ago
ended his career and switched into a
trade
the trade by far in two years he was
making what he was making doing his
college career job
and
he thinks that
college is like a waste of money now
that he's been in the trade and
he also believes that my son or our son
i should say sorry um will appreciate
money more which i disagree if he has to
pay for it himself so um and also in
addition
i don't know how long it will be but the
union has started a program where they
pay 100 of the college but the degree
options are limited at this point so
there's that kind of ball in the court
too as well
okay
um
well i paid for all three of my
children's college education
and it had nothing to do uh that did not
cause them to
not have an appreciation for the dollar
all three of them understand work ethic
all three of them understand the value
of a dollar and so your husband's full
of crap
on that subject
i have proof otherwise
um
now i understand because i come from the
same
i've cut out the same cloth he's cut out
of he believes in hard work he believes
in earning your way and he believes it's
good for your kid to build those muscles
of self-reliance and
uh destiny and uh control you know i i
agree with all that i've got a friend
who's a nfl football player ex-nfl
football player who grew up blue collar
dad there was a dock worker and his dad
said they're not paying for nothing he
went to school on a scholarship playing
football and then went on into the nfl
and he refused in the nfl making nfl
money to save anything for his kids
college so
uh but uh the idea that the only way
your child learns
the value of a dollar is to make sure
they have no dollars is bullcrap
okay but they but i do understand his
line of thinking so i don't disagree
with i understand how he got there he's
just wrong okay so you can teach a kid
the value of a dollar you can teach them
hard work even if they come from a
family of means even if they come where
they have a college fund um and
uh
you can actually hold it over their head
to make sure that they learn these
things you know um
and the other thing i would just say is
the other place i
and i do agree with him that the trades
are oftentimes a better option than a
stupid butt degree
that is nuanced and has absolutely no
application in the real world i'm going
to get a degree in german polka history
and left-handed puppetry and then [ __ ]
and moan because society owes me
something while i'm a barista that's
just dumb okay and that happens all the
time out there and i don't i agree with
him that we're not going to salute that
stupidity either but to say that all
kids don't need a four-year education is
ludicrous it's nonsense so let me let me
tell you this um my grandmother my
grandma
smoked when she was younger
she when she passed away she did not
pass away from lung cancer
that doesn't mean
that lung cancer doesn't give you or
smoking doesn't give you cancer i think
we've proven equivocally that that
smoking increases cancer rates
exponentially
just because your husband got a
four-year degree and has found more
success in a trade
doesn't mean that all people who get
four years degrees are dumber than
people who get go to trades that's just
not how it works
i nor does it mean the opposite would
mean the opposite that if you're if you
get a trigger to a trade and don't go
get a four-year degree you're dumb right
because there's some people need to do
that too we need people on the trades we
need people
but but to not have a money allocated to
cause the future success of your child
whether it's a certification as a diesel
mechanic or and pay for that or whether
it's a four-year degree in business and
pay for that uh you're giving your kids
options when you do that when you have
no money set aside you took away a lot
of the options that's right and i will
i've got several friends who had
assistance with with financial
assistance uh my family was in a
position to do that
and i will tell you we are the same age
and we all equally work really hard
and the their ability to do some things
early on when it came to investing when
it came to home buying that i wasn't
able to do has
accelerated their wealth building
because they had options and so i'm like
dave i my kids will know how to work
hard they will know how to how to grind
and hustle and what a dollar means
and lord willing if i'm able to help
them pay for their college education um
or their trades i'm gonna i'm gonna make
every effort possible to make that
happen yeah and so here's the thing
100 of the humans out there unless they
have a
a a a mental disability
need some kind of education post high
school
to be financially successful
it's not a hundred percent necessary but
it's 98 necessary
you really don't take a single thing
after high school you are behind the
curve and so you need to go get
certifications in microsoft and go into
technology at the local community
college or tech college that's fine
that's going into a trade you go be a
diesel mechanic that's fine be a welder
that's fine get your real estate license
get your real estate license that's fine
but continuing education throughout your
life
is the path of successful people we have
people that come in here that are 40
years old and applying for a leadership
role in there and i ask them what book
they've read and they can't remember one
well they disqualified
you know you don't get to come in here
and be a leader you're not learning
anything new you always are learning and
so you always want to encourage learning
is a is a
continual process we love books we love
reading we love learning uh but we were
and we respect
your ability to go into the military we
respect your ability to go into a trade
we were spent and those are fine career
paths and we've and the higher education
communities looked down their nose at
them for too long so i agree with
lifting those up mike rowe is a good
friend of mine we're in agreement about
that dirty jobs guy you know and so uh
he's got a whole
movement on the trades thing and but
he's not against college he's got a
degree
you know and this is mr dirty jobs for
god's sakes you know and so uh you know
all of that to say uh i understand
completely and agree with why
your husband is saying what he's saying
but i think he's taking the wrong track
absolutely yeah i i think you i think
you put the money aside
money for
future learning
will never go to waste exactly it's all
it's always the best best build a
culture in your house of hard work and
future learning that's right you know
you're always going to be learning
you're always going to be reading you're
always going to be learning you're
always going to be reading
i was telling the story of our team
yesterday we've adopted a school here at
ramsey that was my old elementary school
and we were able to go in several years
ago and rebuild the library and uh in
the name of in the honor of my old
principle
out of our family foundation now our
company is adopting this and coming
around these 83 teachers and trying to
help them because these poor teachers
man they're just it's just ridiculous
out there anyway but um
when they're showing that video at that
library i started crying i had to walk
out dave i walked out because i was
crying like it came over and it's just
like because that library
is where i learned to read i came out of
the first grade in the second grade not
knowing how to read
and my second grade teacher bless her
heart didn't know how to teach and that
she she worked one year and those
hillbilly kids drove her out of business
and so but um then the so i go in the
third grade reading on a first grade
level and miss mary jane hurt taught me
to read and by the time i go out of the
fourth grade level out of the fourth
grade i'm reading on sixth grade level
so that little library and i've had
seven number one best-selling books sold
25 million books that i wrote
okay that doesn't happen unless you read
a lot yeah that goes with the territory
so learning is a good thing
learning is a good thing so you know i i
love guys like your husband though
sierra i i almost could get on his side
on this except he's wrong he's wrong
thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramsaysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth new work
that they love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney number one
best-selling author and ramsey
personality is my co-host today we'll
take your calls about your life and your
money the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five if you've never tuned
in to the new dr john deloney show it is
wildly popular on podcasts one of the
fastest growing properties
on the ramsey networks right now you can
call in there with questions about
uh mental health issues and boundaries
and relatives and
kids and uh marriage and boy there's
some fun stuff on there and some of it's
just crazier than a bean
there's some stuff on there i love
listening to this show but man there is
some wacky butt stuff coming in on the
phone lines there's some stuff man
people are going through it
people have some stuff some people's
kids
i mean it's it's amazing some people's
that's that's the name of the book some
people's kids some people's kids oh my
gosh yeah it's uh uh but i mean it's uh
there's a lot of pain but there's also a
lot of resolution a lot of hope
uh because you do walk through
i mean psychology and
mental wellness mental health is such a
um
taboo subject because if you label
yourself with one of the disorders or
someone labels you with one of the
disorders or you um
accept that as your identity worse worse
yet
or you uh just decide that's crazy and
you just start calling something crazy
um and it's like uh
all of a sudden it falls off into a
whole different bucket of life it just
goes into a black box and
but and there's so many things though
that people can do that are really
common sense things
in that world that you can t that you
teach and that you believe and man i i
get a lot of listening to it thank you
it's a good show i appreciate that it's
it's very similar to money it's just
become over complicated and over
professionalized and over discussed and
there are some ish times that there are
some very very complex issues
most of the time most of us need to head
towards
simplicity yeah and little common things
just a little common sense here and
um like
no you can't act like that around me
anymore yeah i'm not going to accept
that
that's fat
and i i don't do that i'm gonna leave
right i'm gonna choose to don't do
something two people that do you yeah i
don't do that yeah yeah
that's um you're gonna have to get a
little distance like about a county or
two between us here yes it's not gonna
work
it's
it's interesting man you're going to
rage i don't i don't do raging you're a
bully i don't do bullying yeah it's uh
pretty interesting stuff so um i
appreciate that check out check out the
dr john delony show at
ramseysolutions.com you can get the
phone number the phone number you know
what else up your head
no no 693
3291
ah come on kelly help us out here
she's just looking at us daring us to
not know it
just go to the email okay johndaloni.com
ask a-s
there we go and then you can uh then
kelly will uh
i've got your a triple eight two five
five two two five i got your number
memorized how are you our number power
number i got the ramsay show number
memorized okay all right good good we
got that now okay we've solved all of
these issues
now you can call the doctor john dolone
show and solve the rest of it called
this show for numbers questions
because we don't know any of them
mahmoud is with us in phoenix hey mood
what's up
hey dave how are you great man how can
we help
well
so um
i started uh investing in let's say may
2020 so that's after covered 19 slump in
the market
and back then i was living in a
different country and i used to have
an apartment that i used to live
in without paying anything and so my
investment grew from 100 000
to 180 000
in terms of
my original investment
um in the process in 2021 i ended up
moving to the united states and i got my
first lease end of last year
and
i came here with the intention let's say
to buy property so i had
around let's say 120 000 in cash
to use for a down payment
um
during that period of time the house and
market and the rental market has gone up
extremely high
and particularly in phoenix
yes exactly and at this time the stock
market is not doing well
and
i'm finding myself at a
let's say a point where i have to make a
decision whether let's say to pull
all the cash that i have in the stock
market
to
use
either as a down payment or to pay as
much cash as possible for a property as
as things stand um we will rent them
and so um i'm finding myself at a point
where like
either like
my rent is going to go up by a certain
percentage point
which might you know
well here here's the problem um you're
in a hot rental market and you're in a
hot housing market in phoenix no pun
intended it's 110 degrees there right
now but um
you know so it you you're damned if you
do damned if you don't in a sense right
uh so you're going to pay some money out
for housing period to live in phoenix
right now it is um
it's not a down market by any stretch of
the imagination nor is it going to be
anytime soon
so uh so one thing to do to add here
probably is
i'm open to the idea probably to
relocate it to a little bit of of
affordable market at this time in terms
of housing okay but i think stand like
the rent and market and the house and
market here as you mentioned it's like
yeah it's just it's just quite hot i
mean it's just a it's a wonderful market
and in terms of the economy it's just
booming
and so but the uh but it is it is making
housing
um rough
so anyway wherever you're going to live
take your time
not two years but not two days don't get
house fever and get all hot and bothered
and pay too much for something
so go take your time analyze the market
that place the neighborhood you're
looking at work with a good real estate
agent that knows their stuff and don't
overpay
don't overpay
and so
and don't pull your money out of the
market well i would about to buy the
house i would oh you would yeah it's not
it's not in oh it's not a retirement
money it's not in a retirement account
all right my mood don't listen to me
it's not in a retirement account right
it's it's not so i'm just uh yeah i'm
gonna use all the money i get my hands
on to do this deal then
the cat the cash and the stock and the
money you got in the stock market and i
know the market's down it's not a great
time to pull your money out but it's to
john's point but right now what i'm
trying to do is just get you a house and
then get turn and get it paid off as
fast as you can you have an ability to
make money you always have and you
probably will continue to make good
money and you'll be able to work your
way right through this so you're going
to take some losses probably on that
stock market account but that's not the
end of the world go buy you a house and
get you a good deal but go slow don't
get crazy don't get caught up in the
hype because the hype is about over it's
kind of slowed down out there a little
bit
in a lot of places no not phoenix
phoenix is
booming but
you know you and i had a friend the
other day that bought a house and um
the guy had it overpriced because he
thought he'd you know he's gonna get one
of these california sucker fish coming
in here to buy stuff
and that's what we call you california
people that over pay for stuff
and so um but the uh got a good deal on
it but the guy no it wasn't he bought it
from market price
we have another friend same guy
he bought it for appraisal
but 60 000 under asking because the guy
the guy was fishing for suckerfish he
wasn't he was looking for a sucker and
he was overpriced and our guy just said
no and he'd been on the market three
whole days so the seller panicked and
gave it away
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
we are highlighting some discussions on
insurance today we're big on talking
about the importance
of insurance matt is with us in
greenville
south carolina matt talk about how
insurance has impacted your life
hey how are you guys doing over there
today great man how are you
doing absolutely awesome so um it was
around july of 2020 when i was in a car
accident
and uh thankfully because of the
coverage that we got that we got
through
you know through the coverage of an elt
i was able to
um i was able to have not only money
from uh
from uh from the company but also from
our emergency fund uh to be able to
replace that car within a couple of
months
but the funny part is a weird time to be
buying a car wasn't it
yeah
but uh summer of 2020
yeah
tell me about it
but the funny thing was like not even
six months later my wife was in a car
accident
and so we had to go through the whole
process again
no way
no i am not kidding you and it was and
it was one of those just after we had
recovered from that now we got to go
back to the emergency fund again
to hit uh to take care of that along
with what we got from the insurance
company but thankfully we were able to
replace that and by the summer of 21 we
were actually able to finish building
our emergency fund and now we're saving
for a house very good
so you have a heightened awareness about
all this insurance stuff for sure then
don't you
yes sir so what do you tell somebody
when they act like they don't need to
worry about insurance because you're
like a walking claim
yeah uh it's not a matter of if it
happens to you it's when it happens to
you so i know it'll sound like a big
expense and then one of those things
that's just kind of
but when it happens to you you'll be
glad that you have it amen amen
so you went through the confidence in
your coverage series with george
campbell right
yes i did excellent he did excellent on
that by the way he did i thought it was
really good it was funny and fun and
informative and it was short
it didn't it didn't show it didn't show
you down too much so what was the
biggest thing you got out of that
uh just the urgency to be to get this
stuff done now it's
one thing i tell people don't think
about it as part of the baby steps just
take care of it as soon as you can
that's exactly right i agree with that
completely well matt thank you for
sharing all that that's actually great
great input very very good stuff so if
you want to see this uh five video
series confidence in your coverage you
can go to ramseysolutions.com
confidence and it is a free five video
guide on insurance it is short it is fun
it is funny and it is informative so
it's not too painful george makes a a
pretty yucky uh subject uh entertaining
as often george does so uh check it all
out ramseysolutions.com
confidence oh by the way it's completely
free brian's in omaha nebraska hey brian
welcome to the ramsay show what's up
hey dave how's it going better than we
deserve how can we help
uh yeah um so my question is well i
guess there should be a little bit of
backstory um
me my girlfriend and my six month old we
moved out of the apartment that we were
staying at um
they were raising the rent on us and
then uh we just our her parents decided
to
let us stay at their house until we were
able to
save enough money to either buy a house
or rent another another house
or apartment and
basically
i feel kind of i feel kind of horrible
for doing that i don't feel like
i i don't feel like as
good as i should because i know saving
up is what we need to do and i know i
have some debt to pay off so i want to
use the opportunity to
actually save and pay off as much debt
as possible before um the six months
to a year is up that they had allowed us
to stay
um but
i mean is it i guess one of my questions
is is that is that the right thing that
i did
or should i have just kind of
manned up and try to pay
the extra money that they were charging
or and then also um i mean what's the
next step here because i know
paying the debt off is a big one but
it just doesn't feel like i can do it in
the amount of time that i'm being given
so let me jump in
number one
paying an accelerated rent rake has
nothing to do with manhood
uncouple those number two why do you
feel awful you said you feel awful
um
i've always been that type of person to
never accept
help
so okay
you feel like you feel like a charity
case you feel like you're failing your
wife and your and your kid
yeah
okay
how old are you
uh 26. what do you do for a living
i'm a mechanic for a dealership cool
what do you make
um
i haven't completed a full year um so i
know i get paid about 2 800 a month i
think over a year
can be 40 or 45 thousand yeah sounds
right
and uh after you've completed your year
does your income go up
um i am not entirely sure about that i
know after like six months they did it
did come up pretty good
um
but uh after a year i believe
it should i just don't know how much are
you asi
uh asc no um i have a couple ases done
but not completely certified um i guess
that counts and then the dealership that
i work for they have their own training
that they want to hear from foreign
she doesn't um we haven't been able to
afford like daycare so she's a she stays
at home
well if she made 100 000 a year you
could afford it what does she do
well she doesn't work i know why
does she have a degree
i know she's in school right now um like
i said i'm 26 but she's 20 and she's
going for uh
our sociology
so brian i
i'll just take a page out of my own
story um
i
took on the burden of the student loan
debt
between me and my wife i had about six
figures we did together
um and ultimately we sold our house and
i moved us at my insistence um
and she went along with it into a
residence hall a dorm
with a two-year-old
and i felt like a loser
and i felt like a failure
and
i looked at the math
and i came to terms with the fact that
the single
most quote-unquote manly thing i could
do
would be to
have a really hard year an uncomfortable
18 months
and in that 18 months we didn't spend
anything
and we paid off six figures in a very
short amount of time
we took i took extra jobs i worked like
crazy
and in retrospect i can't think of a
better thing i did to stop the madness
stop the sunk cost stop dumping money
into my pride and ego and to stop and
say i need help
and the help came through this this area
right and then we got after got to work
and then put a period at the end of that
sentence and moved on
asking should you have moved is if
you've already moved so asking yourself
that question's a a waste of energy
asking yourself should you move again
maybe that may be another question to
ask
but going back and saying and debating
that decision you already made it man
let that roll off don't carry that
sucker around with you
how much debt do you have
um i have about
6 000 in credit cards um 500 in school
loans
um
17 in
and car payments and then
um
who has the 17 000 car you or your wife
i do um it's the only reliable car we
have but uh right now i know that
um
it's got some hail damage that is
getting repaired as soon as that gets
repaired i know i'm gonna try and get
rid of it as soon as possible yeah good
and get you a hooptie
and get yourself out of debt it's a good
time to be selling a used car
okay um
here's the thing
um i don't know how mature emotionally
your 20 year old wife is but she needs
to make some income
even if it's working from home
even if it's selling stuff on ebay she
needs to get off her butt
and you need to get off your butt and
figure out what your income is and how
you can go make more you don't even know
what you make for sure and you don't
know what your uh promotion process is
you need to go get some money both of
you and get this mess cleaned up and get
your autonomy back and get your
sustainability back and when you get
autonomous again on your own on your own
two feet and both of you have a plan
you're going to be making some money and
you're going to be winning again but
right now you're just wandering living
in your mama's basement her mama's
basement
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage jack
and brittany are with us hey guys how
are you hi there good how are you doing
better than we deserve welcome where do
you live uh we live in houston or
corrections cypress texas just uh just
north of houston texas very cool welcome
to nashville thank you all the way up
here to do a debt-free scream how much
did you pay off uh we paid off
338
405 dollars excellent how long did this
take
about seven years and 10 months good for
you guys i love it and your range of
income during that time uh we started
about 107 000 um
and with a second job we are now about
200 maybe a little over
good for you what do you guys do for a
living i work in the fire department as
a firefighter and my wife's a elementary
school teacher oh cool what grade do you
teach third grade oh fun yeah good for
you thanks for being there thank you we
need people like you out there right now
good stuff well done what kind of debt
was this three hundred and thirty eight
thousand over seven years is that the
house
it is yeah yeah yeah
it is it was a couple of small credit
cards uh
some things we bought for that house
um
vehicle loans and then of course last
and not least the mortgage i love it
look at it weird people
how old are you two
i'm 36 and she turns 21 thursday
thank you
i'll be 35 on thursday yeah
happy birthday thank you way to go
what's the house worth uh about 450 000
maybe you know maybe more 38 bids later
i don't know but and you own it
and you're not even 40. i love it you
guys are amazing
congratulations thank you so seven years
ago you're in your 20s and you decide
you're going to be weirdos and pay off
your house before you're 40.
tell me about this story how did you get
connected to ramsey how did you start
this process um we were introduced to
financial peace through my sister and
brother-in-law
started watching the videos and just
made the decision that we were ready to
change our lives
yeah yeah i'm a
love math um i love numbers um so when
we started looking at a bigger house as
we grew our family
um
that started to scare me a bit
so i didn't really know
if we could afford it and that kind of
thing with growing the family and and
child care and groceries and and going
out to eat and all that stuff so
um i mean that's kind of how we we we
got connected we haven't ever really
been bad with money more just
disorganized if you can say that so
mm-hmm
okay but going into the financial piece
you just said game on
uh yeah we did um yeah we we we laid out
the the plan um as you said it and um
and just went from there yeah you know
the weird thing is is that our
data on people going through financial
pieces they average paying off their
home in about seven years uh the average
millionaire pays off their home in uh
11 years and the average millionaire
listening to our stuff is 10.2 years so
that's actual hard data the other
stuff's anecdotal but um the earlier one
but you guys fit the mold exactly so
well done you're well on your way to
being millionaires then also so how much
is in your retirement accounts
uh well with the recent downturn of the
market uh that put us just under um so
well you were millionaires
yes yes you were yeah okay and as soon
as the market turns back up a little you
will be again yeah we're just just under
the mark now way to go guys and you're
not even 40 baby step millionaires wow
i love it and i'm just a fireman and i'm
just a teacher i could never make it by
the way the number three
uh occupational people who become
millionaires as teacher
and so uh y'all are the fun ruiners
you're the excuse takers right yeah
anybody who's out there whining i teach
third grade i'm a millionaire but i'm
35. exactly
how were you able to be a fireman
without like a huge f-350 all jacked up
in
a hundred thousand dollar truck on
payments how were you able to make it
man
yes uh it was it was tough
they gave it to you huh as we we got
further towards the end of our journey
you know our
income is a lot we're throwing a lot at
the house and um you know new trucks
right right there driving into the
station every single day
it hurts
so it's it's rough and they let you have
it too huh oh yeah yeah
they did they did they're not
millionaires they don't have a paid for
house
that's true you keep your dad gum truck
all right i love it that's just awesome
man
wow way to go how does it feel it feels
great yeah it feels great you got to be
a captain of your own destiny man i mean
you're incredible yeah it does this this
month uh well now probably
maybe a month or two ago it's probably
it's finally set in we paid the house
off january 20
uh 24th i believe um
and uh
we really haven't had you know january i
we we do a lot of dirt bike riding uh as
a hobby so our headquarters had a wreck
hurt my knee i had to repair the bike
and things like that and then
um ac went out in the house of course uh
two months after we paid it off so just
things like that happen so it wasn't
till about april or may when we really
started
we don't have any plans for this extra
money now you know that kind of thing so
imagine 10 years ago
versus
when your air conditioner went out this
time it was just annoying
right it was it was annoying yes it
wasn't right what are we gonna do you're
not looking at two little boys saying
what are we gonna do yeah right
yeah
that's made the process so easy that's
with anything i mean with gas going up
to five dollars a gallon just about
i mean it's just an inconvenience for us
really it doesn't stop us from doing
uh what we enjoy you know and uh
and um and you know we're still
investing and saving and
and and just cruising right along giving
you know that's one thing that we've
really
um
that we've really noticed is is is just
it is huge yeah well we can give back
yeah it's fantastic guys
very cool good for you guys thank you
well done well done we're proud of you
all right you brought the kiddos with
you what are their names and they just
bring them up we have trevor who's 11
and owen that's eight all right very
good good job
good job all right what was the hardest
part of this for you guys
i mean
you know we didn't have very many
arguments over it you know we both were
pretty you know together on doing it
um
but that's i mean
no real hard part except for just
sticking with it you know and and
waiting for that light at the end of the
tunnel yeah
like i said earlier i was a numbers guy
so i i wanted to throw just about every
penny we had
at dead and then of course at the house
so
you know we had a few disagreements
about what we put in the envelopes each
week or each month we do ours every
every week
but
we had a few disagreements then um
and now she she helped work me loosen up
a little bit and release some of that
grocery money and and fun money and
things like that absolutely absolutely
well you should buy your own baby steps
four through seven yeah both those boys
do have shoes on so that's good
way to go you guys all right uh what do
you tell people the biggest key to
getting out of debt is
um i think it's it's like the
other debt free scream said earlier the
budget um and communication
um you know when we started we were
writing it down and and now you know
we've kind of gone electronically but
um
but communicating and having those
discussions
um being content
with uh with uh with what you have
and and i think it just it all it all
comes back down to the to the budget and
and we
you know we didn't stop spending we just
put it down on paper and organized it
and and still you know still did our our
snow trips um you know once we got out
of our consumer debt and still did
um some disney trips and things like
that but
uh intentional but we just saved for it
you know it took us a year to save for
it but we saved for it you know and so
and just making the money behave all the
way that's it you ever go back in debt
uh sir no sir no no not even for an
f-150
i got close uh and i don't know how much
time we got left but i got super close
and almost made a mistake a very small
mistake and taking another loan and uh
and my wife and brittany she snapped me
back right real quick
but
i didn't save for a year
for disneyland for you to get a definite
i love it way to go you guys all right
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
of financial peace university and total
money makeover for you count it down 338
000 house and everything baby steps
millionaires in seven years making 107
to 200 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three
two
one we're free
that's how it's done
this
is the ramsey shaft
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about life
and about your money open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
uh max is with us in salt lake city hi
max welcome to the ramsay show
afternoon i appreciate you accepting my
call sure what's up
yes sir so i'm a 50 year old married now
um been married for about seven years i
believe
we could retire um but i'm
not sure if we should
okay
what's the what's the goal here what's
the goal what do you want to do i i
guess i guess that's the concern um
we've been we've been very fortunate
we've played by the rules um i've had a
spreadsheet budget that each tab goes
back to all the way to 1999. wow um and
so i had if you it's kind of like a link
leading the rings on a tree if you go to
a certain tab you can kind of see what
happened in my life
in that specific year
um but we have four rental homes uh we
have one one pension already secured and
we receive that each month my wife works
and i also have another career now
we should get a second uh pension uh in
five years when i'm 55 through the
military
um and so i guess and what is your net
worth
honestly i i don't know uh when you
account for our full rental homes they
are paid off uh we live in the fifth
we've lived in a fifth wheel for about
five years now so that we can make uh
have cash flow through the rentals
um i would estimate probably six hundred
six hundred fifty thousand uh
net net
net worth
um and i guess the biggest concern and
you hit it on the nail on the head when
you said what's the goal um each what i
have found that
for very long time now i've always had
woken up and had a goal had something i
wanted to achieve had something i wanted
to you know
a medal i wanted to put on my chest or
something i wanted from my wall
um
i never thought that uh 50 years old i
would kind of be lost because i don't
know if we should go for a fifth home
i don't know if we should just call it
good we're making now uh 14 14.2 a month
net
our total expenditures each month
outflow are about 2.3
um
and i i
i kind of had this wild dream of i'm uh
i've been a private pilot since i was 18
to 32 years and i was talking to my wife
that maybe maybe someday i can take
about 35 000
and go after a uh instructor rating and
maybe i can do that part time
until basically the faa says
i'm too old to do it but then i don't
think i'm going to make the return on
the investment if i did that i guess i'm
just looking for some
something to wake up in the morning for
but the money's easy the numbers aren't
easy um
but now that we're here
i don't know
yeah
i do want you to change gears though
from doing your duty
uh because you're a man of honor who's
always done his duty
to uh finding something that you make
money doing while actually enjoying it
and i don't care if you make a lot of
money it wouldn't make me mad
the challenge about the
questions the challenge about the
question you're asking max is you've roi
joy
you've put a spreadsheet to what matters
and you you've spreadsheeted out
relationships you've spreadsheeted out
excitement you've spreadsheeted out
happiness you've spreadsheet out joy
and
it's very hard to capture those things
with it with it with a 10 key
and the the challenge is you're asking a
question what what can i go do what can
i go seek that's going to fill that gap
inside of me and
that's going to come from the inside out
not the outside in
so the question dave is asking you as a
profound one what do you want to do man
yeah and so here i'll give you a hint
okay
um
i'm gonna send you uh ken coleman's a
career assessment and his new book from
paycheck to purpose because what's
missing here is purpose
yep um and uh i'll give you a place to
look
find something where you're serving
other people and making their life
better that makes you smile
and then i want you to do that
with great scale and go make a million
dollars doing that
because you're only 50. you've still got
20 or
25 good hard years of work
that you can bring value to other
people's lives
and
by the way if you do that in a proper
way inside your skill set
they will give you as my friend rabbi
daniel lapin says certificates of
appreciation with presidents faces on
them
when you serve others and make their
life better they are grateful just like
when you have a great
experience in a high-end white
tablecloth restaurant
you are more than happy to
say thank you to the person who served
you by leaving an outrageous tip
and that's the way the economy should
work is when we serve each other
um there's a transfer of wealth that
results and i want you to get that
um
because you've just been grinding
on my notes here dave as he was talking
you could see the word i wrote i wrote
the word service oh i just wrote that
word down as he was speaking
the only way out of this trap is to go
be about making somebody else's life
better and it doesn't have to be a
non-profit nope
um
you know we can argue that steve jobs
like him or not like apple or not made
lots of people's lives better with these
magic wands we carry around in our hands
called phones
that we can do anything with now
and uh became bazillionaires because
they made a lot of life people's life
better and we can go on from there or
something as silly as you were with me
at a park a few uh maybe a month or two
ago
and your wife and henry cloud had to
peer pressure me into getting on a
roller coaster because i'm scared
terrified of heights that's my that's my
thing
and the other day you and i jumped out
of an airplane together
um with a guy with parachutes with
parachutes yes we made it but
otherwise we would have left our mark
but somebody left it all on the field
served us laughter and joy and
overcoming fears and that dude was
incredible and he kept us safe and he
walked us through it
that's a service as far as i mean it was
it was a thing they were incredible
incredible the team
you know made skydiving not terrifying
yes yes which is less than i can say
about you pulling us on a tube behind
your boat right
but here's the deal i was trying to
serve you sir you
you you served you up to the water i'm
about 18 lake water right now yeah um
but service can look like a lot of
different things but it's going out and
say where can i bring people joy where
can i meet a need in the enviro in the
world that's not being met and go do
that thing for other people
right
absolutely
yeah that that's going to help in this
situation so mathematically you can do a
lot of stuff
you've got some pensions and you've got
some margin and you've got some net
worth
and you've got time
i do think you need to change gears oh
i'll tell you the book you ought to read
i got it it's called half time
by bob buford
and
bob the thesis of the book for those of
you that haven't read halftime it's an
old book but it's a great book
is that
men particularly males um when they
reach half time in the game
they go from acquisition
to significance
and if you don't move from acquisition
in the first half of your life to
significance in the second half of your
life
if you don't make that move uh you're
susceptible to midlife crisis blondes
and convertibles wow and so you're going
to find significance doing something
you're going to find excitement
doing something in the second half first
half is just grinding and acquisition is
fine and by the way the first half is
not a chronological thing it's an
emotional thing i did my half time at 28
when i went broke and so i reached the
point after going broke i don't give a
crap when anybody thinks i'm gonna do
what i'm supposed to do i went to
significance which is this thing has
been i've done for 30 years now plus 30
plus years
so um been on the air for 30 years
but uh uh the uh but that's that that
whole movement there's a movement there
that's tied to the midlife crisis idea
and all that kind of stuff but you know
you're just having a uh chronologically
a little bit later half time and doesn't
mean you're emotionally stunted that's
not what i'm saying but this guy you
know that we're talking to here max but
i i think you know hey
you know what's the next adventure yeah
look for an adventure of service a man
without a purpose is an untethered scary
dangerous
person go find a purpose man yeah yeah
sir hang on i'll have austin pick up
we're going to send you a copy of that
um
can call allikin's materials and uh
assessment and the book as well from
paycheck to purpose
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work that they
really love and create actual amazing
relationships dr john deloney ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author mental health expert is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
and your money and your life
it's a free call a triple eight eight
two five five two two five lynn is with
us in
rochester new york hi lynn how are you
i'm great dave how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
okay well um when i said i was great
honestly
we have a crisis and we need your help
shelby um my husband was offered a job
in north carolina and granted it's only
fifteen percent for excuse me fifteen
times more an hour
but
what we would save in taxes and
everything else would be
astronomical
um we put our home on the market the
real estate agent said that we will get
we should get 169 for it
hopefully there would be a bidding war
but
he said the market's kind of soft so it
might not happen
we found out that we have a mean on the
home
from past medical debt
of 21 000 and we owe 120 000 on the home
so if our home goes from 169
after we pay the lien and pay the home
off we're like we're gonna net
seven to ten thousand
and my question to you is should we take
it off the market
and just
hammer out the debt
and then go forth with north carolina
what is the
era what is the history on this 21 000
medical debt
i was in a car accident
10 years ago and we fought back and
forth with the
insurance um
to take care of it they never did
and then my husband i got ill with lupus
and wasn't able to work and my husband's
sole provider so things got pushed off
to the side and that was wonderful so
the moral of the story is uh that um
ignoring things doesn't make them go
away
exactly yeah
so you have a 21 000 medical debt that
they finally sued you on and took a lean
against your house on but have never
garnished your wages and that that
lawsuit was how long ago
yeah how long ago
um
how long ago
um oh goodness probably five years ago
they are garnishing his wages now
i bet they are
okay
when were you all planning on dealing
with this
well
to be honest because they were taking
his wages we're like okay
because we're paying it
we just assumed naively i guess that's
even a word that what is your what is
your household income
my husband makes about 70 000 with over
time
and the move to north carolina was
prompted by what
what makes you want to go down there
we felt
years ago god's calling us to north
carolina and just we love the area we
love the people
and
just life in general we feel would be
better there because here in new york
the taxes are astronomical i need more
pain okay here's the thing um if you
sell your house you get a fresh start
and you get rid of this mess that you
haven't dealt with and you get to move
on with your life that's a beautiful
thing okay
the only downside of that process is you
probably could negotiate this 21 000
debt
uh
you know you probably offer them five or
ten dollars they'll probably take it as
settlement in full
do you have the ability to borrow any
money
no we don't
could you go to your credit union and
get five or ten thousand dollars
we might be able to uh
my husband's credit isn't the greatest
right now no kidding because of the
debt
right i know big surprise
okay so i would ask your credit union if
there's any chance that they would loan
you five or ten thousand dollars don't
take the money if they approve the loan
though get that in writing and then go
to the lawyers uh that have the that
have done the lawsuit on the medical
debt and see if you can settle this for
a quarter or 50 cents on the dollar if
you can do that that'll get the lien
removed for less than 21 000 and then
that would put a little more money in
your pocket as you sell the house
if you want to go that route you can if
you don't want to go that route just
sell your house at least you'll be rid
of the garnishment and you will have
gotten this from over the top of your
head but please for god's sakes learn
the lesson from it
the lesson is this stuff doesn't go away
unless you make it go away
it just gets worse it's like a splinter
under the skin
that's very true yeah ignoring it these
things have a high rate of resurrection
they come back
over and over and over and over again
and so you have to push that stuff
through and i'm fussing at both you and
your husband for your own good because i
want you to prosper and you're not going
to prosper with that habit in place
so
yes i'm selling your house
uh yes i'm going to try to settle that
debt for less than the face of it is
because it is a 10 year old medical debt
and they probably will take less on it
um but
maybe they won't now that they've got a
garnishment and also about when you get
to north carolina it may mean you have
to rent for a year or two yeah you don't
need money yeah you can't come in here
and just buy your dream house in north
carolina yeah right and uh but 15 cents
an hour raise with no income tax and no
garnishment
that's bigger than you don't feel bigger
than 15 cent an hour raise i feel like
you've won so um yeah you're going to
come out ahead that way so and you know
you get a fresh start and you kind of
get a you know different different
setting and everything so i'm with you
on the move overall and that's what i
would try to do megan is with us in
atlanta hi megan how are you
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call how are you better than we deserve
what's up
all right
um well i am just looking for some
advice so
um last october i got a um
bill in the mail that i owed verizon
wireless four thousand dollars and it
ended up being a fraudulent bill i have
never had or i had an account many many
many years ago with them
i worked with i have
in place identity for protection i
worked with my team there in getting
that all resolved
i thought we were all good with
everything
i
ended up buying a condo not too long ago
and
so have been
paying pretty close attention to my
credit report and i just got a message
last week that i owed
forty six hundred dollars to a
collections agency yeah standard you
have to go back to your identity theft
protection again that's what it's for
and they will have to work it through
that's the only way you can do it
there's not even there's no way around
it that's the downside of this
the good news is if you have good
identity theft protection like xander
insurance
then they will do the work for you and
fight these things off and push them
aside
have bad they make you do half the work
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
well we've spent a couple of uh
call segments talking about insurance
today
and uh we've got amir on the line in
denver
hey amir uh tell me how things are going
with you brother
i am first of all i'm doing better
better than i deserve sir
i love it very good
thank you i'm very very excited to talk
to you well thanks for calling in to
talk about this insurance stuff uh talk
about insurance and how it impacted your
life
absolutely so i i want to start by
saying that
you literally saved my life and i'm
going that's regarding the insurance and
we're going into it now
our story goes back to 2016 when i start
listening to your show
and my wife and i never really had any
debt except for a mortgage but since we
left israel and immigrated to the states
after the age of 30 we knew that we are
way behind in our retirement savings so
i was searching online for all kinds of
advice when i stumbled upon your plan
and at that point i learned that i am
underinsured for my life insurance
according to what to teach and my wife
had no life insurance at the time since
at that point she wasn't working
so of course i reached out to xander go
to quote for new life insurance for both
me and my wife
and while my wife was a food was
approved within a couple of weeks my
application was denied because of
irregular activity of my heart that was
seen on the ekg test at that point i'm
reaching out to my physician with the
decline letter we are starting doing
investigation and we found that i have a
genetic heart disease that put me at a
risk of a cardiac arrest
and while the
disease is not curable i do have an
implantable defibrillator today that
will kick in and save my life if
something would happen
since i am not insurable anymore because
of this issue uh we decided to go
gazelle intense in paying off our
mortgage
which we did in less than four years and
i do know today that if something would
happen to me my at least my wife and
daughters will have a roof over their
heads and hefty savings so at the end it
was a blessing in disguise since we may
not have learned about it until it would
have been too late you discovered the
health problem because of the insurance
application that's amazing
wow what a story man you've been through
so much
that's crazy so do you you went through
this uh confidence in your coverage uh
series the five video series with george
campbell what'd you get out of that
well
it gave us it gave me the assurance to
know that i am well covered at least
where i can be covered and and um
we did not really miss anything and i'm
i'm very happy i do have a financial
piece by by doing that yeah well you got
a little piece of mind now that you've
yeah because this whole subject's uh
kind of been had like a highlighter over
the top of it for you man that's pretty
crazy wow well congratulations man and
uh thank you for calling in i'm glad
your health was discovered and got that
underway and it also helped you adjust
your overall financial plan that's crazy
dave i
i just had to catch i almost got choked
up there
the difference between somebody who gets
life
deals them a raw deal
just hands them a bad set of cards
and you either fold up and quit playing
or you say
thank god i'm all right now we got to do
something different
i don't know if i could bottle that up
and write that book man my grandkids
would never have to work yeah but he got
they looked him in the eye and said you
might die so we have to put a machine in
you
and what you can't get insurance and
instead of going home and saying well
crap that's it for me he said we're
going to do something really different
we have to pay this thing off at least
my wife will be okay here
that's courage and bravery that is
missing from society in mass to say
here's what life dealt you man and it's
not good it's not right it's not fair
and so what are you gonna do and that
dude said i'm gonna do something
different yeah
it's very cool that's incredible man you
know there we see that a lot that common
thread among people who
are able to win with money they they
manifest something like that uh
the old book seven habits of highly
effective people by dr stephen covey the
number one habit is the people are
proactive they happen to things things
don't happen to them yeah
they're victors not victims yeah and uh
so all of us have crap coming at us i
mean everybody does and the question is
are you gonna stand on it or lay under
it yeah and man that guy's a he's a stud
that's incredible man really cool yeah
so good hey guys a lot of you are uh
concerned all the way to panicking about
the real estate world out there
on july 14th we're hosting a free live
stream called real estate reality check
george campbell rachel cruz and i are
going to walk you through what's going
on with the housing market today and how
it all works so you know how to navigate
it spoiler alert the housing market's
not going to crash
it's not
and we're going to show you with data
not emotions not politics
why
we're going to teach you where real
estate prices come from
and we're going to walk you through the
facts the data the charts the graphs the
economics
completely free
july 14th a free live stream real estate
reality check
and uh so far tens of thousands of you
have already signed up to watch this
it's at 7 pm central time july 14th
about two weeks from now ramsey
solutions dot com slash reality check
will get you signed up our question of
the day comes from blinds.com they have
a 100 satisfaction guarantee that means
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your window
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from ashley in
ohio ashley writes my husband and i
fight all the time and need counseling
in our finances we're pretty equal with
spending but i get blamed for being a
spender he makes 200k a year and we are
out of debt
except for our house we have about nine
years left on our mortgage and i'm sick
of pinching pennies i compared myself
with our friends all the time we make
more money than so many people and yet
we have old cars
i'm over it and i'm to the point where i
could go back in debt to live and say
yeah kids more
how can i get out of this mindset
i need some more information here for
this one dave but
you've dealt with this a long time i
i have a hard time with
the limited data set i have here um
i have a hard time with the attitude i
guess i struggle with that hers yes
and it may be again some more data would
let me know if a husband is
super controlling and won't let anybody
spend anything or he only gets to spin
things
um
but when it comes to i compare myself
with my friends i'm ready to get back
into debt so we can go have some fun
i have a hard time with that one i also
have a hard time making 200 000
and you all haven't created space for
y'all to enjoy your life
right yeah
um
i i may be
reading too much into this but i just
see two selfish immature people yeah
both of you want your little thing
and neither one of you are willing to
put the other one first number one and
worse than that neither one of you are
willing to put the good of the overall
household ahead of your own little crap
you're acting actually you're sound like
a spoiled princess it's just like a
child or
you are
a
a wife who has absolutely no vote
because your husband's an overbearing
ogre nerd with his spreadsheet but he
gets to do whatever he wants right both
of these are selfish immature reactions
what both of you should do
is look to say okay what is the best
plan
for the good of our overall household
and what is that
you know what is the best plan we have
taught that the best plan to do is
called the baby steps and depending on
where you are in the baby steps it
sounds like you're in four five and six
then you don't have to pinch pennies if
you're out of debt everything but the
house
and you have an emergency fund in place
but you two have not done a budget that
you both agreed to that was aimed at a
bigger goal than either one of you
the only thing you do the reason you
have fights is when you sit down you
want to get what he you want he wants to
get what he wants instead of going okay
what's the big goal you're not dreaming
bigger than either one of you your dream
is
i want something i want equal
we need a big goal that's bigger than
either one of you
a bigger vision a better clearer vision
that you both can buy into and you're
both willing to sacrifice equally to hit
that goal and consistently to hit that
goal
but this sounds like two kids fighting
over
who you he's got my toy he got my two
and i want my like my grandkids when i'm
keeping
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america on july 14th we're hosting a
free live stream event called real
estate reality check if you're wondering
about real estate and what it's going to
do
we're going to give you data not
feelings we're going to give you facts
and historical perspective
on the best way to look at this
situation and what are you really facing
out there should you be scared is the
market going to crash spoilers
spoiler alert no it's not go to
ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck and get your tickets for a
free
oh
calling from tacoma washington camera
and esprit are with us it says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations how much of you paid off
hi dave we paid off 150
507.86
love it how long did this take
43 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh we started off as a two income
household making about eighty thousand
um and by the end we were down to a one
income household making about eighty
five
ha i like it that's a great increase
what do you do for a living
uh i'm in commercial tire sales
very good
and she's not now right
that's correct
anymore
i love it what did you do before a spree
um i was a social worker very good in
foster care good oh that's a good
calling fun okay and what was the 151
thousand in
debt uh well it was a little well not a
little it was a lot of everything
um we had credit card student loans car
loans personal loans you name it we had
it y'all were like normal
yeah
just regular old walking around
americans
and you woke up one day and said this
sucks
we need to change how did you find out
would you decide to do this ramsay stuff
um so for us we
i mean we have like this rotating cycle
of money fights right and one day i just
happened to see one of our friends
celebrating completing baby step number
two on their facebook asked them about
it and
um we went to go enroll and we actually
couldn't afford it because you guys
don't accept credit cards and we were
like oh this this is a really big issue
um and so we saved up and
enrolled in fpu and it's you know
history ever since yeah very cool
because it's 99 whole dollars
and uh yeah and if we took credit cards
that would be pretty hypocritical don't
you think yeah yeah right yes exactly
oh man i'm so proud of y'all so you
signed up for fpu and that starts the
whole thing four years ago huh
yeah wow so tell me what happened after
that you went to class and were you both
ready i mean
or one of you kicking and screaming
against it or what
um
i uh was definitely the the last to come
on board
um you know after the the first
meeting and you know we were talking
about
on the car ride home uh we actually got
into a little argument because uh i
didn't want to sacrifice uh you know i
didn't want to give up my stuff i just
saw a picture of you with that nice
f-150 you wanted to hang on to that
truck huh
yeah that was actually um
that was a dave car
so we had
probably about three or four months
before we started fpu we had both
purchased two brand new cars
um
that ended up going away oh and the
truck was a downgrade that's a downgrade
yeah sweet deal on it yeah good for you
man okay i'm going with that good i'll
go with that
20 volt yeah yeah it's a 20 year old
truck
oh it doesn't it looks like the picture
makes it look good okay good all right
so you got rid of uh what did you sell
off
uh i had a ford focus st little sports
car
and uh she had a a regular ford focus
okay wow good
i could say something smart i look like
you went up but anyway
but um
so but anyway
well congratulations that's a big deal
man when you go through that internal
battle
with yourself
to say okay
i don't really want to live like no one
else so that later i can live like no
one else but maybe i should maybe i need
to maybe i've got to grow up and you you
wrestle that guy to the ground
and to say i've got a sacrifice to win
and i don't like it that is a real adult
manly thing to do dude
thank you
it's hard it wasn't easy it's an
existential struggle
yeah i i really like that car
yeah yeah even though i made fun of it
but yeah yeah i'm with you i mean i get
it
that's
you know
when i i distinctly remember when i was
coming out of the whole process of going
broke and i had to look in the mirror
and not in a shaming way but just in a
truthful way and say
you're the problem
and you by god are going to be the
solution you know i mean i had this
conversation with myself looking in the
mirror in the bathroom and it's just
like ah
you're killing me right you know and
it's just this this sling this internal
wrestling
and you guys decide to go
uh
and change your whole lives i'm so proud
of you
thank you
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that ish
um i would say
don't be afraid to get back on track
when you slip up
because we definitely did over the
course of you know almost four years
um
you know be intense be intentional
and don't carry shame because that
causes you to isolate and then you
don't give yourself room for support
it sounds like a man who's gone to
counseling huh
or a wife who was a social worker oh
there you go
even better no wife who teaches
counseling there we go yeah that's good
well that is true that is true the uh
the only difference in shame and guilt
is uh one one of them defines who you
are and the other one just is an
admission of stupidity
and you move on right and so it's not
it's not who i am it's just something i
did something i did that's right and um
that i'm not going to be shamed by my
past that's why i can say you know i
lost everything i got a phd into umb and
i can do it with great freedom um
because that's not that is not who i am
it's something i did 30 years ago so uh
and it set me up to win like never
before and also to help other people win
like never before so so proud of you
guys your heroes well done well done
well done
who are your biggest cheerleaders
definitely each other right we depended
on each other but
i actually have two really good friends
that have also went through fpu
phyllis and taylor and they really
cheered us through we were um
our money eaters were food right
groceries and eating out and we all kept
each other accountable
um so definitely definitely them
like-minded people help you along the
way big time
good phrase very good phrase yeah you
need community uh for accountability and
for encouragement to bust you uh and
also to you know hold your hand when
you're just weak you know it's just we
all need that
good stuff you guys well done well done
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure uh we've
also got a fresh one-year subscription
to financial peace university you can
give that to someone it is all the brand
new videos the best fpu we've ever done
and uh also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and get
someone started way to go you guys
very well done cameron and esprit in
tacoma washington 151 thousand in 43
months making 80 to 85 and she was able
to quit work and stay home with a baby
and still got an increase in income for
him over the whole net of the thing well
done you guys count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
love it
so great man
don't be normal
be weird
so great don't be conformed to this
world
be transformed
by the renewing
of your mind
well done you two
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 90 12 teach us
to number our days
that we may gain a heart of wisdom
thomas sowell says life does not ask
what we want it presents us with options
that's the truth
oh and those debt-free screams we're
always giving away a one-year
membership to financial peace university
which includes the premium version of
every dollar it automatically connects
to your bank with all your different
debit card usage pops right into your
budget you're going to love all that if
you want to do all of that just get you
a
financial peace university membership
gift card
very easy to do
just check it out at ramseysolutions.com
gift and you can sign up for that and
give it to someone and if you wanted to
give financial peace university away
that's how you do it these days and that
way they've got access online to watch
the videos and they can go to a local
class if they want as well it's all
available all for one price
ah you gotta love it open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five hunter is with us in greenville
south carolina hi hunter how are you
um right now i'm nervous because i
didn't think that i would actually get
through today how are you guys well
we're honored to speak with you how can
we help
yeah
um so i come from a family where
financial literacy wasn't really taught
we didn't talk about money we saw
parents put everything on credit cards
live on debt paycheck paycheck um that
changed when my husband and i got
married we went through the baby steps
um we paid off all of our debt two years
ago and we're currently saving for a
house down payment right now good for
you you broke up change yeah where'd it
go yeah yeah
unfortunately my sisters are all still
kind of stuck
in that um living paycheck to paycheck
living in debt and we find ourselves
constantly bailing them out and even
today one of my sisters
called me
in tears asking for money and um they're
in a really deep hole and of course i
have this is the third time we bailed
her out and given 1500 over the last
three months to some of my sisters to
build them out
um and so i'm just trying to find the
balance of like when's enough enough is
it okay to put stipulations when you're
giving money to family like hey i'm
going to give you this but like i want
to i want to sit down and do a budget
with you or it's like that overstepping
i don't know that's kind of my question
i'm looking for advice and guidance how
old are you
um i'm 26.
how many sisters three
i have three sisters two older sisters
and one younger sister okay
um hunter i i'll let dave answer the the
back into this but
it sounds like you're giving money less
because they need it and more you feel
like you have to
whether that's from a place of guilt you
quote unquote got out or you just feel
like it's your job am i am i right
i would say that's true i definitely
come from like an
emotionally manipulative family okay i
don't really have too much to do with
like my parents and things like that too
much anymore um and i i don't know i
guess i feel a sense of responsibility
for them because like i see where we
were kind of let down and i found a way
out i guess maybe um i don't know i just
i don't want to see them struggle
and
nobody wants to see somebody they love
struggle and at the same time
um
you can't help her be in better shape by
running her miles for her
yeah you can help with a workout plan
you can call and check up on her and see
how her workouts are going you all can
run together but she won't lose weight
when you don't eat that's right you
can't run her miles for her so
my recommendation listening just and
this is not for everybody this is just
listening to you
is that you and your husband stop cut it
off and that may be an email that says
we're no longer going to support in this
way but right now you need to get okay
with you and you're not there yet and
giving
letting that money leave to try to help
you is different than i see a need i'm
going to go meet that need right now
you're trying to meet your own needs
right um and then dave you've you've
taught me a lot about stipulation it's
your money to give right you can put
every stipulation on it you want to
because it's your money
you have absolutely zero moral or
spiritual obligation for a sibling who
is misbehaving
yeah none
i set you free right now
it's not your job
it's not your job yeah
it's hard to watch
it's very hard to watch people you love
be stupid
yeah
they like and
bought a house they just bought a house
and
like i invite like they came to me for
advice i'm making their budget to buy
the house and i was like look i really
don't think this is in y'all's budget
because before when we bailed them out
we did you know i said i said
they went against your advice and bought
something they couldn't afford and then
last week they came to you for money
yeah well today they came to me for
money but yeah
did you give it to him today
um i did send her money today and i told
them i was like oh i want to sit down
with both of you guys this time because
like you can't do it on your own like
you and your husband have to be in on
this
and he doesn't see the need to sit down
so he doesn't have one because you keep
giving money yeah she doesn't have a
need to sit down yeah
yeah that's true so
not because it's the right thing to do
morally because you are a classic
enabler
yeah you
enablers don't put stipulations on
giving a drunk a drink
okay
now there's nothing morally wrong with
giving the guy who says we'll work for
food money at the corner because he's in
a hard time that's fine
but if we wanted to love him better
we would stop
take the time which takes more time to
love someone well
it's more inconvenient and we would walk
him over to mcdonald's and buy him a
meal
if he would go no
if he really will work for tell us tell
us what's going on he may just flip you
off and tell you to get off his corner
but um in which case you know i think we
found out the real deal right which it's
some of both when the guy's standing out
there with a sign and so
you want to love people that are hurting
well
uh but loving them well does require
stipulations it does require boundaries
not for you
and not because it's the law
but because
what is good for her
what you've been doing has not been good
for her you've been financing her crazy
butt life
that's not been good for her you've been
giving a drunk a drink you've been
harming your sister
that makes sense yeah
yeah oh no it definitely makes sense
your lack of courage to say no or not
put stipulations on this because you
felt somehow you felt better if you just
gave her money she would go away without
any kind of a conflict or without any
kind of her mother's manipulation come
your manipulation coming out of your
sister's mouth directed at your forehead
uh you didn't want to deal with all that
and so you cheaped out and gave her
money
it's a make no mistake when you draw
this boundary she's going to be pissed
she's going to come run and bang up
against that boundary and see if it
holds yep and you are going to can't
believe you're doing this to us we hate
you oh you're miss goody too shoot oh
you're rich all figured out yeah you
forgot your raisin expect all of that
and the pain and that is first what's
wrong with you i can tell now that you
married him right you're gonna hear all
this bull crap redneck bull crap i can
hear it right now doesn't mean it's
wrong doesn't mean it's wrong okay yeah
yeah
i can say that because i know it well
personally okay so
uh
not not not as a not putting somebody
down not you anyway so anyway this is
what's gonna happen the same stuff that
you distance yourself from your parents
is what's going to happen when you draw
this boundary now what you can do though
is just be loving and kind and gentle
and say i would love to help you
when you complete financial peace
university
and i get to see the budget that you two
are doing together
if i can participate in some of your
getting out of debt process and you're
getting in control we'll try to do that
i am no longer going to give you money
without you having done that though
or what john said is okay too
just to make sure you first get whole
and you're doing this from strength just
say you know what i would if i could but
i can't right now i don't feel good
about the way this is going i feel bad i
feel like i'm bringing you harm and i
just can't do it anymore i'm so sorry i
love you but i just can't give you money
yeah
if she says well if you know if you
really love me you give me money well
listen if you have to buy your
relationship that's called prostitution
that's true it's not a real relationship
yeah and so you know that's that's the
deal so if she puts a boundary on you
that says the only way we have a
relationship is money then we know how
things do it
so and after you get your house you you
save up for your house you get it paid
off i mean you get your down payment
ready to rock and roll then you might be
in a place to say okay let's sit down
and have this conversation but you need
to heal from the inside out too yeah
it's okay to say no and you really
really need to that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john dolone co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you